started off with amply circling the
building and actually being trailed by
literally hundreds of journalists and
cameras I think it was quite a bizarre
sight for the residents here who were
hanging out their windows watching it
was the sort of site that I think might
have been faintly amusing if it wasn't
though worrying that were there were
armed police scouring the building and
eventually they took axes and to the
door to great get into the church and we
had about ten minutes where they were
literally banging down the door and I
again I think that would have been
extremely worrying for residents not
knowing what they were looking for who
potentially was inside but a team of
arms please 20 inside they were in there
for about 10-15 minutes eventually came
out left the building so it may just be
that they are searching scouring the
area making sure that there's nobody
hiding in any of the building part of
this raid on the apartment has finished
but they have now left and moved away
but it was quite a you know a strange
scenario I think for a lot of people for
a period of time everybody's hearing the
news now that things are over they're
asking questions about who has been
killed they want to know the identities
because residents here heard from very
early in the morning the suggestion that
the masterminds of the attacks on Friday
and potentially the man who's been
called for the last few days and most
wanted individual in Europe people had
heard that they potentially were at the
heart of their community